then i read my third script that i got  my hand on and it was walter hill's  script for his first movie as a director  hard times  but when i read hard times  then i could see what a script could be  it was exciting  it was fun and it wasn't just the  dialogue it wasn't just description  it was  pros now not pros like i'm used to in a  novel but it was a prose that was  appropriate for a screenplay he was the  pros was written for me the reader  i was supposed to get caught up into  this i was supposed to to be excited  about this story i was supposed to get  caught up in the story and even more  importantly i was supposed to make the  movie in my mind when the script was  over and i put it down i saw it i saw  the movie